all the plants and microorganisms which
has chlorophyll are able to perform the
reaction called photosynthesis and one
phase of the photosynthesis is light
dependent and another phase is
apparently light independent the light
independent phase is known as Calvin
cycle it appears to be bit more
confusing and lot more steps involving
in this process so in this video we are
going to really break down calvin cycle
into bare-minimum
and simplify it so stay tuned till the
end of the video let's look at where
does calvin cycle take place so inside
the plant cell there is chloroplast and
if you zoom into the chloroplast we
would see there are stack like membranes
which are known as Tyler quads and this
tile acquired lumen which is the cavity
of the thylakoid is a site for the light
reactions whereas the external part
which is known as stroma is a site for
the light independent reaction so the
light reaction requires direct
impingement of the photons or the light
now this is very complicated and in a
different video we will be talking about
the light reaction but for now we are
not going to talk about light reaction
let's just bypass the light reaction and
try to understand what are the key
products that we obtain in a light
reaction so the key products which is
generated in the light reaction is ATP
and NADPH these two products would be
used in the light independent reaction
and this would be very essential for the
Calvin cycle
so the calvin cycle is a three-step
process it can broadly divide it into
three step the key goal of calvin cycle
is to fix co2 which is taken up from the
atmosphere now the co2 is fixed in form
of a three carbon compound known as
phosphoglycerate and later on this cycle
goes on and on to
more carbon and ultimately generating
sugar so from co2 you get sugar this is
the sole goal of the Calvin cycle at
first sight it might appear bit
confusing so let's look at the Calvin
cycle stage by stage the stage one is
carbon fixation so in the carbon
fixation reaction the first compound
which up takes like co2 is basically
Regulus Biswas rebellious 1/5
bisphosphate or rubp
and the key enzyme participating in this
process is Ruby's Co rebellious
bisphosphate carboxylase so as the name
suggests it performs a carboxylation
reaction and attaches a carboxyl group
and ultimately it forms 3
phosphoglycerate two molecules of 3
phosphoglycerate let's look at this
process in a bit more details
so the first step which is catalyzed by
Rubisco is basically carboxylation and
it occurs via a in dial intermediate
here you can see a double bond and
followed by two alcohol so it's in dial
intermediate and now the carboxylation
reaction can take place the carbon
dioxide is incorporated into the rebel
O's bisphosphate followed by a
hydrolysis step it forms two molecules
of 3 phosphoglycerate so 3
phosphoglycerate is a product of carbon
fixation in the Calvin cycle reaction
now let's see what happens to these 3
phosphoglycerate molecule so in the next
phase what happens is this 3
phosphoglycerate is actually
phosphorylated using a enzyme known as
phosphoglycerate kinase as the name
suggests it's a kinase enzyme so it
could phosphorylate right so it would
form 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate it has 2
phosphate group and this phosphate group
is labeled in red and this phospholipid
this phosphate group comes from the ATP
but we will come to that
after this 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate is
converted into plis are all dehyde 3
phosphate
now this step is catalyzed by
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate dehydrogenase
as the name suggests it's a
dehydrogenase enzyme it would perform a
reduction type of reaction so let's see
in the first step where we first focus
red kinase works the phosphate group
comes from the ATP and this ATP was
generated previously in the light
reaction and now in the second step
where the reduction reaction is taking
place the ridi reduction equivalent is
obtained from NADPH and the NADPH was
also generated in the light reaction
phase though we call calvin cycle a
light independent reaction because it
doesn't require light impingement
directly but you can see right now that
the products that are formed in the
light reaction is very much crucial for
this Calvin cycle reaction to occur
right so it is not completely light
independent I would say now the last
phase is to regenerate Rubisco it's to
regenerate the regulars bisphosphate
because this reaction need to go on and
on in order to fix more and more carbon
dioxide in form of sugar so you really
need to regenerate this part is very
complicated and not necessary
so what would happen is from
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
some of these glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate
pool would go through a complex process
and forming several sugars of like five
carbon 7 carbon three carbon six carbon
etc and ultimately regenerate the
regulars b15 bisphosphate such that the
reaction can the Calvin cycle can go on
and on and more carbon fixation can take
place now all of these sugars which are
intermediates can be taken and used in
several metabolic processes of the plant
and that is how the calvin cycle takes
place I hope this was very easy and
understandable if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up and don't
forget to leave a comment up to this
video your comments give me so much
motivation that I can make more
thank you